where we need to win
and where we haven't won for decades in
all four corners of England in Blackpool
Middlesbrough Dover Medway Plymouth
Swindon Stoke-on-Trent once again the
largest party in local government
[Applause]
all of which I'm reliably told means the
real winner last week was Rishi Surak
a brilliant strategy a master stroke to
lose a thousand seats honestly even by
Westminster standards the spin last week
was quite something
but all that noise it's water of the
Ducks back it will never distract me
from our ultimate goal you know when I
was younger I was a decent mid-distance
runner racing across Surrey in the 1970s
not actually where you might think it's
all breeding ground for Progressive
politics
but one thing any Runner will tell you
is that the hardest yards come at the
end
so make no mistake we are on track
on a path towards power
but there's still more work to be done
a lot more work to be done
and the toughest part lies ahead
we've got to show
not just reassurance not just that we're
better than the tour is last week's
results show people they already get
that
the task now is to measure up to the
scale of change that Britain needs
demonstrate that we can be the Hope
working people need get our purpose our
pride and our future back
restoring hope for working people
it's a simple aim
but it's what we've got to be about
a politics that use this power to fix
problems not protest to grab the
Limelight
as my project
respect
my guide unlocking aspiration my cause
and the goal is for a labor party that
speaks for fights for and wins for
working people
[Applause]